when you recorded American Idiot when
the whole album was done
you cried oh did you know that yeah yeah
I think right I think this is while
we're recording the song what's her name
you cried because the exhaustion was
over I mean right I can imagine writing
it now but putting out an entire body of
work the pressure of having that God
knows where it all comes from I'm sure
there are times you say Dee so I don't
even know if I have another [__] song
in me I mean it's each time is a
difficult process yes yeah yeah yeah I
mean it's your brain working on
overdrive for a couple years straight is
that why you cried because of exhaustion
I was hungover - oh there was that I was
this kind of listening thing and just I
think it would the sonically when I with
the way that Mike was playing and I
think it just got like a just a kind of
a bittersweet moment right there let's
go to American Idiot and let's all think
about the fact that there was such a
relief here you were hungover the album
is over and you were in tears yeah I'm
gonna keep that image in mind as we hear
American Idiot live from our Hollywood
studios let's do it
[Music]
don't want to be an American II
joana nation under the new media
[Music]
they can you hear the sound of the
series
the supplement on my [__] America
[Music]
well maybe I'm the [__] America
I'm not a part of my god Jim
everybody to the pub again
[Music]
let's stay on longer they hate you're
paranoid
[Music]
it's calling out to idiot America
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god that looks like so much fun
look at that